hold hold we're standing down to do a
t-tab ground issue
standing down inside three minutes of
launch SpaceX and NASA scrubbed a rocket
launch to the International Space
Station overnight the launch director
stopped the countdown as you just heard
to investigate a possible issue with the
ignition of the Falcon 9 rocket engines
on board two Americans one Russian and
an astronaut from the United Arab
Emirates they were ready to start a
six-month mission NASA now says the next
attempt will be early Thursday morning
if everything checks out meanwhile there
are four other astronauts waiting on the
space station for their ride home